oui
moss le mot ce maintien vous êtes là
vous n'avez pas deux chargements
l'histoire de la magie a écrit pour
demain et vous vous pensez vraiment que
c'est prudent de laisser votre dragon
tout seul dans le salon tout comme une
partie de ma génération j'ai grandi avec
harry potter
j'ai découvert la saga les 8 9 ans elle
m'a accompagné jusqu'à mes 18 ans 11 ans
j'ai bien évidemment attendu avec
impatience ma lettre d'admission à
poudlard
qui ne rêverait pas d'intégrer une école
de magie et quant à la fin de l'été ne
voyant pas mal être arrivé j'ai dit à ma
mère
mais maman je n'ai toujours pas reçu ma
lettre pour poudlard
avec le secret espoir qu'en fait il est
oublié de me l'envoyer cette satanée
lettre ma mère m'a dit tu sais chérie
peut-être que poudlard n'existe pas
alors j'ai pris une grande aspiration
j'ai avalé la couleuvre et je fais comme
tout le monde je suis allé au collège
quinze ans plus tard la raison pour
laquelle je suis devant vous ce soir
c'est pour vous dire que poudlard existe
oui poudlard existe et pas seulement
poudlard
tous ces mondes fictionnels que vous
adorez celui de doctor who does the
walking dead la terre du milieu ouest et
ross
tous ces mondes existent ils sont là à
portée de main tout ce qu'il suffit de
faire c'est de dépasser les frontières
quand je lis que ces mondes fictionnels
existe je ne réfère pas au fait qu'ils
existent dans votre tête ou dans votre
coeur bien que se doit c'est vrai je
parle d'une existence beaucoup plus
matérielles alors bien entendu
hélas les lieux de tournage et les lieux
réels mentionnés dans ces univers
fictionnel la gare de king's cross à
londres par exemple ou les parcs à thème
comme le parc harry potter à orlando
mais ces lieux ne recréent que fit que
partiellement un univers fictionnel
partiellement car s'ils sont
matériellement reproduit autour de nous
si nous immerge dans une certaine vision
de ces univers nous n'en sommes pas
vraiment acteur nous sommes plus que
jamais des touristes dans ces univers
or les univers fictionnel ne sont
réellement reproduit que si nous ne
sommes pas spectateur mais acteur et
quand je dis nous je parle des fans bien
sûr les fans ce sont ces publics
véritablement investis dans un univers
fictionnel selon la définition du
chercheur américain engine kane
les fans sont des gens connectés dédié
réunion communauté est engagée d'une
multitude de façons différentes et
surtout qu'on se l'avouer ou pas la
majorité d'entre nous sommes les fans
par exemple qui parmi vous soutient une
équipe de sport et se considère comme un
fan de cette équipe
ouais c'est tout d'abord essayer autre
chose et qui parler vous êtes fan de
musique un groupe de musique un petit
voilà et y at il parmi vous des fans de
jeux vidéo de séries télé et de films a
alors ça en fait des femmes ce soir être
fan va au delà d'une simple catégorie
c'est une véritable expérience constitué
de pratiquer d'activité
il ya parfois une certaine
performativité du fan c'est en
pratiquant des activités de fans qu'on
peut devenir soi maman fans pour ma part
c'est en fréquentant les fans de game of
thrones dans le cadre de ma thèse que je
suis véritablement devenue une fan de la
série
avant je ne voyais plus comme une
spectatrice
mais c'est en intégrant les groupes de
fans en échangeant avec eux puis en les
rencontrant lors de conventions que je
me suis véritablement considéré comme
une fan de game of thrones
les fans de mondes fictionnels
constituent une communauté riche qui
produit consommé se mobilisent les fans
s'intéressent au travail de leur père
mais également à toutes les productions
issues de l'univers qu'ils admirent
livres films séries télévisées jeux
vidéo et j'en passe le transmédia c'est
à dire la déclinaison d'un produit ou
d'un univers sur différentes plateformes
en ligne et hors ligne fait partie
intégrante de leur expérience
mais les femmes ne sont pas que des
producteurs et des consommateurs
ce sont aussi des citoyens ce sont des
gens qui contrairement aux idées
préconçues se mobilisent dans la sphère
publique
les fans de harry potter sont
particulièrement présents dans cette
mobilisation de palets valeurs nous
transmise par la saga de jk rowling le
courage et la force de ses personnages
inspire ses fans dans le monde réel en
france des étudiants de l'université de
rennes ont présenté pour la première
fois en 2015 une liste intitulée l'armée
de dumbledore qui visait à défendre le
droit des étudiants à l'échelle
internationale on peut citer l ong de
harry potter qui développe des campagnes
en faveur de la justice de la littératie
et de la lutte contre le sexisme et
l'homophobie
cette ong est l'exemple type de
l'activisme dont les femmes sont
capables
parmi les fans de mondes fictionnels
certains recrée véritablement l'univers
qu'ils aiment et le fonds ancien et
grands ils deviennent acteurs de
l'univers ou des univers dont ils sont
fans
comment font-ils cela grâce au cos clé
le cosplay c'est cette pratique dans
laquelle les participants portent des
costumes afin d'incarner un personnage
fictionnel le kospi est une pratique
créative très complète qui va de la
recherche de tissus à la confection de
costumes en passant par la création
d'objets et de bijoux les cosplayeurs et
font preuve d'une véritable puissance
créatrice dans la mesure où il dépasse
le cadre développé par la fiction il
plisse cette dernière à leur vision et
adapte le monde fictionnel aux
contingences de la réalité et le fond
pour une raison simple
quel meilleur moyen d'être acteur d'un
univers fictionnel que d'y incarner son
personnage préféré
ah non non non
personne n'a jamais dit que les
baguettes magiques ne fonctionne pas
dans star wars
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un crossover
c'est à dire le mélange de plusieurs
univers généralement des univers dont on
est fans ici harry potter et star wars
harry potter m'a accompagné tout au long
du collège et du lycée
mais ce que je ne vous ai pas dit c'est
ce n'est pas vraiment harry potter qui
était avec moi c'était d'hermione
granger
c'est à elle que je m'identifiais c'est
elle qui m'a fait comprendre qu'il n'y
avait pas de mal à avoir de bonnes notes
à l'école et à aimer les livres
si amiens de granger avait le droit
d'être bonne à l'école tout en vivant
des aventures extraordinaires alors je
l'avais dossier ce dont je parle quand
je dis que poudlard existe c'est que
poudlard existe non pas via des lieux
mais grâce à des personnes la véritable
immersion dans le monde d'harry potter
c'est celle qui consiste à incarner un
personnage de la saga et à le faire en
étant entouré de gens qui font de même
les cosplayeurs se réunissent le plus
généralement lors de conventions les
conventions ce sont ces rassemblements
de fans de divers univers qui ont lieu
plusieurs fois par an partout dans le
monde
en france nous avons la japan expo le
comique de paris où le toulouse game
show parmi tant d'autres j'ai
véritablement découvert ces événements
il ya environ un an avant je les
regardais comme la majorité d'entre vous
je pense c'est à dire en me demandant ce
qu'étaient ces endroits étranges et je
dois avouer au risque de sembler cliché
qu'ils ont changé ma vie ils ont changé
car j'ai découvert ce que je ne pensais
pas y trouver
j'ai découvert des communautés de fans
soûlé mais surtout des milliers de fans
réunis paisiblement
j'ai découvert que dans ces lieux je
pouvais être qui je voulais de moi même
au monstre aliens le plus terrifiant
mais surtout j'ai découvert que je
pouvais me plonger dans chacun des
mondes qui me plaisent en joignant les
communautés le cos payeur et en les
regardant incarner leurs personnages
car la personnification joue un rôle
crucial en le cosplay il ne suffit pas
de s'habiller de se coiffer comme le
personnage représenté il faut aussi
jouer ce personnage
d'où le terme cosplay constitué des deux
mots anglais costume et play le jeu
d'acteur et les mises en scène
développer
ah les cosplayeurs permet de recréer
l'ambiance des mondes fictionnels ils
foutent les frontières entre fiction et
réalité au comicon de londres par
exemple les cosplayeurs se retrouvent
par univers fictionnel à l'extérieur du
bâtiment et donc on peut voir sur l'a20
groupe de docteur issus de doctor who
auprès de cosplayeurs de game of thrones
et puis là-bas un petit peu plus loin
des costières d' assassin's creed ces
groupes de cosplay heures crée des
bulles la fiction dans lesquels on peut
s'immerger pour quelques instants
que l'on soit face payeurs ou non le
cosplay est une pratique ouverte à tous
j'ai commencé à causse plié il ya
environ six mois c'est peu dire que mon
nouveau que mon niveau en couture est
lamentable et que je suis loin d'être
expert du tressage de perruques mes
gènes
incarnez un personnage auquel je tiens
j'aime le temps d'une convention pouvoir
enlever julie s craignant chercheuse et
devenir julie cosplayeuses fans de game
of thrones d'harry potter et de la momie
j'aime être entouré de gens qu'ils vont
pas regarder si ma jupe est trop courte
mon visage trop maquillée si la bonne
taille deux ans la bonne couleur de peau
j'aime savoir que je peux venir de
france ou d'ailleurs être religieuse ou
athées manger de la viande votre vegan
ce qui comptera vraiment c'est que je
suis une fan une fan et une cosplayeuses
le cosplay est ouvert à tous et permet à
chacun d'être ce qu'il veut on peut se
payer un homme si on est une femme et
vice versa on peut copier un personnel
jeune si on longue paume - ou un
personnage de vieillard si on est jeune
on peut que se plier un seul personnage
à la fois où un mixer plusieurs dans un
même costume quand on pratique le
cosplay qu'on se retrouve lors de
conventions
ce ne sont plus la nationalité l'âge le
genre la religion la couleur de peau qui
compte c'est uniquement l'attachement à
un univers fictionnel le fait d'être un
fan et la traque aux payeurs et c'est ça
qui est beau des gens de toutes origines
qui laisse de côté leurs différences
pour se concentrer sur ce qui les réunit
sur un objet commandes d'amour et non de
haine la plus belle chose que j'ai
entendue à une convention
c'est un participant qui disait que s'il
y avait plus de cos payeur dans le monde
ce dernier serait sans doute un endroit
plus pacifique
alors quand je disais tout à l'heure que
pour atteindre poudlard
il faut dépasser les frontières je ne
parlais pas de frontières physiques
je parlais en partie de savoir dépasser
la frontière entre fiction et réalité
pour s'immerger dans le monde qu'on aime
mais je parlais surtout de savoir
dépasser ses propres frontières
cela peut-être faire un premier pas pour
aller une convention un deuxième pour
parler à un cosplayer cela peut-être de
laisser de côté ses préjugés sur les
gens qui ce costume ou ses idées
préconçues sera quoi devrait ressembler
tel ou tel personnage cela peut être
tout simplement d'être maître qu'on est
un fan parce qu'il est encore des
sociétés des cultures et des
environnements dans lesquels les plus
difficiles de se reconnaître comme fans
quel que soit votre frontières vous
gagnerez à la dépasser
il est au monde robben il est où mon
bruggen allait bien d'organes on va
conquérir westeros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]